Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du Linus, ich will jetzt auch endlich mal was sagen.
Ich kann nicht gleich hochziehen oder hast du überhaupt schon Inweit? Ich weiß gar hast du ein iPhone?
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertsiebenundsiebzig, wir schreiben Freitag den zweiundzwanzigsten Januar zweitauseneinundzwanzig neue Präsidenten, neue Perspektiven
immer noch Pandemie und ganz viel Audioprobleme bei dem Versuch, uns hier irgendwie remote zu verbinden.
Das ist wirklich frustrierend ähm mit diesem Internet, dass.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht, oder? Das kann man auch einfach mal abschalten.
Ja, manchmal denke ich, es wäre vielleicht besser gewesen mit dem Mist gar nicht erst angefangen, aber das sind die dunklen Stunden.
Meines Daseins.
Das lässt sich jetzt leider nicht mehr zurückdrehen, da müssen wir ja jetzt durch. Wir müssen, wir müssen mit dem Netz leben, so wie wir es haben, dass das grade in Deutschland nicht besonders einfach ist, dass äh wenn wir im Laufe der Sendung dann auch nochmal behandeln tja.
Also wie gesagt, wir werden im Laufe der Sendung noch lernen, dass noch nicht entschieden ist, ob sich das hier mit diesem Netz dauerhaft in Deutschland durchsetzt, etabliert oder nicht, ne? Das äh ist durchaus noch äh hier Neuland.
Ist auch die Frage, ob's jetzt überhaupt noch Podcasthörer gibt, weil irgendwie gefühlt sind ja jetzt alle gerade im Clubhaus.
Oh ja, äh da kommen wir dann auch gleich zu. Das werden wir nicht vermeiden können, aber wir möchten kurz vorher einmal über unser Feedback sprechen. Wieder viel Feedback
zur letzten Sendung. Herzlichen Dank, es waren eine Reihe an Korrekturen dabei, die ich euch natürlich nicht vorenthalten möchte
Und zwar ähm habe ich in der letzten Sendung so sinngemäß gesagt, der Grund, warum die USA mit Wahlpersonen wählen,
lege daran, dass die, dass es ja ein Flächenstaat ist oder ein äh äh dass die Vereinigten Staaten ja Flächenstaaten sind und man irgendwie zusammenkommen muss, das ist aber
äh nicht äh richtig diese Vermutung. Da wurde ich unter anderem korrigiert von Stefan und Wilbert. Stefan sagt.
Da hier die Wahlmänner hinterfragt wurden, der historische Grund war,
dass sich die Föderalstaaten nicht auf eine gemeinsame Art der Präsidentenwahl einigen konnten. Die einen wollten Volksabstimmung mit Mehrheitswahlrecht, die anderen Staaten Verhältniswahlrecht,
und andere Staaten, dass die Föderalstaaten Regierung den Präsidenten bestimmt, also unterschiedliche Staaten werden vereinigt und haben unterschiedliche Vorstellungen, wie denn der Präsident gewählt wird.
Und deswegen haben sie sich dann, hat man sich dann das europäische Kurfürstensystem.
In Klammern gewilkürte Monarchie als Vorbild genommen. So konnte jeder Föderalstaat komplett selber bestimmen wie sich seine Stimmen verteilen,
und es gibt trotzdem eine gemeinsame Wahl. Das ist also der Grund für dieses äh Wahlpersonenrecht.
Okay, das wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Und äh dann sagte Wilbert dazu noch, ergänzend noch der Hinweis, dass sich die Wahlfrauen und Männer, die zusammen das sogenannte Electric College bilden, nicht,
im Capitol in Washington, DC treffen, sondern Mitte Dezember gleichzeitig aber jeweils in ihrem Staat zusammentreten. Also alles, was ich da gesagt habe, ist falsch. Ähm
über äh die Historie und den Ablauf dieses äh Wahlvorganges äh korrekt war, aber ähm dass am sechsten,
Januar äh Leute randaliert haben, den Teil habe ich richtig.
Gerade noch die Kurve gekriegt, Mensch.
Dann haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass äh Trump ja oft den sozialen Netzwerken gesperrt wird und da gab es auch, denke ich, zwei wichtige,
Ergänzungen. Ähm einmal von YO, äh der kommentierte,
Ein Aspekt, den man in der Debatte um die Twitter-Sperre und so weiter auch beachten muss, auch wenn die Bewertung,
schwer fällt, ohne total zynisch zu werden. Trump wurde von Twitter gesperrt am Tag nachdem die Demokraten die Mehrheit im Senat gewonnen hatten. Also da,
jetzt nicht mehr die Republikaner mit ihrer Interpretation von,
zu halten sind, sondern eben die andere Seite. Auch wenn sich Jack Dorsty jetzt mit denen gut stellt, bleibt er eventuell von Regulierung, die manche Demokraten schon angekündigt haben.
Verschont oder.
Also wenn und wenn sie sich mit denen jetzt gut stellt, bleibt der eventuell von äh Regulierung verschont. Na ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall der Zeitpunkt.
Sehr unglücklich gewählt und da kommentiert auch Obstsalat etwas, was wir in der letzten Sendung wirklich haben zu zu kurz kommen lassen. Wir haben nämlich relativ ausführlich von Sonderregelungen in diesem Fall für Staatsoberhäupter gesprochen.
Aber ähm korrekt merkt Obstsalat an Donald Trump hat ja nicht erst als Präsident angefangen, gegen die Community Richtlinien von Twitter zu verstoßen.
Bevor, sondern er hat das auch schon getan,
bevor er Präsident der USA war, konsequenterweise, so Obstsalat weiter, hätte man ihm bereits zu diesem Zeitpunkt den Account sperren können, ohne das Risiko einzugehen, der Öffentlichkeit, Äußerungen von besonderer zeitgeschichtlicher Bedeutung vorzuenthalten
Aber Twitter hat sich lieber,
über seine eigenen Richtlinien hinweggesetzt, da Trump früher als Demagoge in Erscheinung trat und damit versprach, tankerweise Klicks
zu generieren. Das ist, denke ich, hier sehr wichtig ähm,
zur festzuhalten, ähm dass potentiell Twitter und die.
Aufmerksamkeit, die Journalistinnen auf Twitter haben, durchaus eine signifikante Rolle gespielt haben kann, dabei, dass Donald Trump.
Präsident wurde. Und ja, das haben wir ähm.
Etwas, äh das haben wir äh unterbeleuchtet, insbesondere in der Würdigung von Twitters Rechtfertigung des eigenen Handelns.
Dann kommt zuletzt noch ein Hörer der ein weiteren Aspekt, den haben wir in anderen Sendungen sehr häufig diskutiert, aber hier auch nicht, da geht's ein bisschen also um soziale Medien generell, also hier um die Frage Pala, ne, Twitter, Sperrung und so weiter.
Alle besprechen, das Ganze immer so, als würden diese Hassgruppen rechte Spinner, Trump-Anhänger, AfD-Anhänger und so weiter sich von ganz alleine finden und zusammentun. Ihr nennt selbst den Gedankengang, das sei einfach ein Nebeneffekt,
davon, dass sich jetzt eben jeder mit jedem vernetzen kann.
Ähm der Dialog wird oft so geführt, als seien die populären sozialen Plattformen flach und chronologisch und als ob jeder dort.
Eigene Hand navigiert. Aber das ist schlichtweg falsch. Facebook und YouTube Algorithmen boosten, bewusst und gewollt seit Jahren immer den Content, der von Facebook und YouTube,
gewünscht wird, dass es aktuell meistens der Content, der die meisten Gemüter erhitzt. Timelines sind schon seit Jahren nicht mehr chronologisch, man bekommt auch hier Content aufgezogen. Ja,
wichtiger Punkt. Ähm ein bisschen zu kurz dargestellt, aber das ist auch völlig normal in einem Kommentar. Deswegen will ich das kurz ergänzen. Warum tun die das, ne? Also es ist ja nicht unbedingt so.
Das Facebook, Twitter, YouTube, äh sich zum Ziel gesetzt haben, lasst uns die Welt äh ähm spalten und Konflikte ähm irgendwie.
Eskalieren, aber dass sie natürlich das Geschäftsinteresse haben, dass Leute möglichst viel auf dieser,
Seite sind und das funktioniert eben äh dann, wenn die Inhalte aufregend sind, Engagement versprechen und das wiederum funktioniert besonders gut, wenn sie irgendwie polemisierend sind. Ähm mit anderen Worten, die Algorithmen, die bei denen,
ja
Sagen wir mal ganz unschuldig kapitalistisch motiviert sind, ja, führen dann eben zu einem katastrophalen äh sozialen Effekten und zu einer Vergiftung des Diskurses. Ähm.
Alles Wichtige, Ergänzungen, die hier eben von Obstsalat, Einhörer und Jo noch kamen, um die Breite dieser Diskussion nochmal äh mehr zu zeigen.
Dennoch würde ich anmerken, dass es trotzdem auch diese Diskussion gibt, ne, freie Rede und so weiter und die Diskussion oder das Phänomen, das sich eben gezielte kleinere Netzwerke,
mit ähm konkreten politischen Ausrichtungen, wie jetzt hier eben Gap und Pala ähm auch.
Etablieren und aufbauen. Ja, also das sind ähm zwei Verbundene, aber nicht,
vollständig gleiche Probleme.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen,
Zauberlehrling reloaded, also dieser Algorithmen äh haben ihn sozusagen businessmäßig vielleicht geholfen, aber sie haben halt einfach spezifisch dieses Problem stark verstärkt
dass dass der dass diese ganze Content-Geschichte und was Leute eigentlich als relevant ansehen, vollständig aus der Hand äh geglitten ist. So, also auf einmal hat sich die die Relevanz quasi selbst verstärkt
ohne wirklich jemals relevant gewesen zu sein und.
Darunter leidet man. Und ich denke, dass dieses Problem aber auch erst so richtig in den letzten Jahren verstanden worden ist von allen
Und das äh ja, das mit Trump sozusagen an der Stelle der größte anzunehmende Unfall war.
Ich finde das lustig, dass du das Zauberlehrling reloaded nennst, ist nicht äh der gesamte Kapitalismus im Prinzip, nur der Zauberlehrling? Also das ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das in anderen Bereichen anders.
Ja, weiß nicht.
Ich habe das so, also mir wurde es als Kind so beigebracht.
Also da da machst du jetzt ein Fass auf, äh das passt nicht in unseren
Plan heute, ne? Und es passt natürlich auch insofern nicht, als dass es jetzt nicht hier vorher irgendwie einen Meister äh gegeben hat, der das irgendwie äh in gewisser Hinsicht im Griff gehabt hat, aber so dieses äh äh so von einem Werkzeug äh auf einmal, also in dem Fall den eigenen magischen Kräften überzeugt
gewesen zu sein, dass doch schon irgendwie hinzubekommen und das so nach dem Motto was kann schon schiefgehen?
So ja, könntest du gerade mal so die komplette Demokratie sprengen und so,
Das haben sie halt wahrscheinlich auch so in der Form nicht gesehen. Facebook scheint's irgendwie von außen betrachtet, immer noch so ein bisschen egal zu sein und ähm na ja, den anderen ähm netzen so wie Pala und so weiter äh eher noch ganz recht
Ich meine, das ist diese ganze MEM Dynamik, so das hätte man schon auch in gewisser Hinsicht sehen können, dieses selbstverstärkende, kulturelle Element,
Vorher war's halt nur Spaß und jetzt ist halt so ein bisschen gefährlich geworden.
Nicht gefährlich geworden ist, äh die Wikipedia. Wir haben ihr ja
zu ihrem zwanzigjährigen Bestehen äh letztes Mal gratuliert und bei diesem äh bei dieser Gelegenheit ein paar äh Änderungswünsche kurz diktiert. Äh die wurden alle umgesetzt. Ähm finde ich sehr schön. Ich hatte ja gesagt,
in der Wikipedia nicht weiter äh als Netzaktivist
äh stehen, weil das die ganze Zeit abgeschrieben wird und ich überall dann irgendwie als Netzaktivist vorgestellt werde. Deswegen wurde das wurde jetzt die Wikipedia geändert, ja. Äh da steht jetzt Ines Neumann, ist Hacker, Berater für IT-Sicherheit und einer Sprecher des Chaos Computerclubs, der Diploop-Psychologe lebt und arbeitet in Berlin. Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Noch ein paar Sätze und dann.
Bekanntheit erlangte er durch seine frühere Autorenschaft beim Block Netzpolitik org durch sein Engagement und Auftritte im
Umfeld des CCC sowie den seit zweitausendelf gemeinsam mit dem betriebenen Podcast wo er sich zum Teil aktivistisch engagiert. Dennoch versteht er sich nicht als Netzaktivist.
Also finde ich äh gut getreut, aber tatsächlich kann ich sagen, danke ähm,
reicht, weil äh die Leute schreiben eh immer nur so die ersten beiden
oder die ersten drei Sätze ab. Und da das jetzt irgendwie so im vierten ist, passt mir das äh so sehr gut, finde ich,
finde ich spitze, vielen herzlichen Dank. Das Bild wurde auch getauscht gegen ein viel cooleres, ja, also von das wurde gemacht bei der
Politik das ist Netzpolitik Konferenz ich glaub neunundneunzig ne neunundneunzig zwanzig neunzehn fühlt sich an wie neunundneunzig aber war tatsächlich zwanzig neunzehn ich bin ich bin rundum zufrieden.
Ähm Wikipedia Spitze. Bei dir wurden auch Änderungen gemacht, Tim, oder?
Ich bin kein Eventmanager mehr. Hurra! Aber äh äh vermisse noch Verweise auf meine besondere Attraktivität und Intelligenz, aber das kann ja noch kommen.
Nee, also sehr schön, äh hat hat funktioniert äh und vielen Dank für diese edits und vielen Dank nochmal,
für diese großartige Wikipedia, wo man ja auch noch sehr viel interessantere,
Personen und Fakten nachschlagen kann als Netzaktivisten und Eventmanager.
Ja und sollte es noch wichtige Informationen zu uns geben, die der Welt mitgeteilt werden, werden wir das dann nachher in späteren Sendungen nachdiktieren.
Ich hätte da ein paar Ideen, was man da noch reinschreiben könnte.
Ich auch, aber das machen wir später.
Wir hatten über die ähm übrigens auch nicht abreißende Welle an Messenger wechseln gesprochen.
Und die finde ich sehr ähm.
Also ich finde das ja erstmal sehr positiv, wenn nun äh offenbar eine Abkehr von WhatsApp
Momentum gewinnt, ja? Ähm Signal hat, glaube ich, inzwischen die Nutzerbasis verfünffacht. Ich muss dazu sagen, dass offenbar Signal,
wohl noch gar nicht so verbreitet war, wie ich dachte. Ja und es gibt natürlich dann auch direkt ähm.
Viele, die sich zu Wort melden mit anderen Messenger-Konzepten, also zum Beispiel sagen, ja, aber die Server sind nicht Open Source und die Bilds sind nicht reproduzierbar. Ne, und da kann ich eigentlich nur sagen, also,
Leute, schaut euch bitte auch mal an, woher wir kommen, ne. Wir reden hier von einer Bewegung von Leuten, die ähm bis bis vor kurzem,
völlig problemfrei WhatsApp genutzt haben, ja? Und wenn die sich jetzt davon wegbewegen und eine,
Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Messenger nutzen,
der von einer ähm gemeinnützigen Stiftung bereitgestellt wird, dann ist das ein riesiger Schritt, ja, und der ist super gut. Das heißt nicht, dass äh reproducibles nicht wichtig sind, aber.
Glaube auch, dass der größere Teil dieser Leute nicht mit äh reproduzierbar gebauten Betriebssystemen irgendwie unterwegs sind. Insofern äh wir müssen eben leider äh die Probleme einen Schritt.
Nach dem anderen lösen und da ist dann dieser Schritt schon ein sehr wichtiger. Nichtsdestotrotz.
Soll man natürlich auch andere äh ordentliche Chatalternativen hier nicht äh.
Ja unerwähnt lassen.
Insbesondere sind da so von den dezentraleren Ansätzen auf jeden Fall Delta-Chat und Matrix noch zu erwähnen, die auch in den Kommentaren erwähnt wurden und das ist äh.
Bei Delta Chat, das ist im Prinzip interessant, dass sie, sie sagen einfach, okay, wir wir nutzen als Basis, ne, als als Transport,
Protokoll ganz einfach E-Mail. Und da drauf machen wir eine Verschlüsselung und bauen quasi, ne, wir wir schicken uns per E-Mail Delta-Chat Nachrichten und stellen die in einer App,
so dar, als wie sie eben im, im, in einem Chat System wären. Das, denke ich, kann man so.
Also es gibt gute Argumente das so zu machen das hat sich auch in vielen Ländern und auch in aktivistischen Communitys wegen dieser Dezentralität,
sehr gut durchgesetzt.
Hat ja zum Beispiel auch den Vorteil, dass es jetzt gar nicht mehr so eine zentrale Anlaufstelle gibt, die man irgendwie stören könnte. Ja, also oder die überlastet werden könnte. Das ist also äh eine schöne Idee und ähm,
ähnlich äh ist ähm Matrix ähm auch von einer Non-Profit,
entwickelt und da geht es eben auch darum, dass du dir quasi eigene Server unterhalten kannst. Das sind alles auch sehr schöne Systeme, wo es sich lohnt, mal ähm reinzuschauen.
Und ähm.
Das denke ich äh kann man auf jeden Fall auch als den nächsten Schritt sehen. Aber ich denke, ein erster Schritt ist erstmal seine Kommunikation und seine Netzwerke potenziell eben,
aus dem Profitinteresse herauszuziehen, wie ich das letzte Mal auch schon gesagt hatte, so.
Ich bin für mich einfach wohler bei einem Dienstleister, dessen Ziel es ist, mir diesen Messenger bereitzustellen, als bei einem Dienstleister, dessen Ziel ist es anderen Leuten äh mich als Werbesubjekt,
anzudrehen. Und natürlich ist dann der letzte Schritt, der hier klar natürlich auch erwähnt wird und angefordert wird.
Zu sagen, ich ich habe die Infrastruktur einfach selber in der Hand, gibt überhaupt gar keinen Grund, mir die von Dritten äh bereitstellen zu lassen. Aber diese.
Man muss eben sagen, dass auch diese dezentralen Systeme, ja, Masterdown ähm.
Und was was gibt's da noch für für Klassiker so, die,
so auf die so dezentrale Ansätze haben. Also nehmen wir mal E-Mail und Mastodon als Beispiele,
Grundsätzlich kann da jede Person ihr eigenes System betreiben, aber es entstehen auch dort leider so etwas unselige,
Zentralisierungstendenzen, ne, dass dann alle sagen, oh, ich will aber bei dem E-Mail Provider sein oder bei dem Mastodon Server, der irgendwie gerade der heiße Shit ist und,
ne und bei Gmail. So als also als Beispiel, dass es eben leider auch in den dezentralen Systemen,
so gewisse Zentralisierungs Tendenzen jeweils gibt.
Auf jeden Fall stehen diese ganzen Messenger äh extrem im Mittelpunkt und Single hat es auch äh erstmalig so in die Top-Charts geschafft
so und war halt für einige Zeit, für,
ein, zwei Wochen, glaube ich, so auch auf Number one oder zumindest so mit Zoom, so in dem Bereich. Und was sonst alles noch so in in Quarantänesituation an nützlichen Tools derzeit angeboten wird.
Da kann ich noch, ich will noch allen kurz ein Feedback zu Signat sagen. Ganz kurz, das haben wir auch getwittert, das kam nur nicht über die Kommentare,
Hat sich jemand bei uns beschwert und sagte, hättet ihr meine letzten LMP Folge Signal nicht Signal empfohlen? Das hat voll den Pulleffekt ausgelöst und die ganzen Flüchtlinge von WhatsApp wollen rüber. Deswegen ist Signal jetzt ständig down. Das Boot ist voll. Wir brauchen hier eine Obergrenze,
Ja, also tatsächlich war's Signal überlastet und äh wir haben natürlich ganz souverän geantwortet mit wir schaffen das.
Ja und da denke ich äh da muss hier die Solidarität einfach auch mal im Vordergrund stehen.
Ja, aber der Spaß war dann auch schnell wieder vorbei mit Signal auf Platz eins, denn äh dort hat's jetzt eine andere App hingeschafft, die jetzt äh alle vollständig entzweit.
Äh Clubhaus ist auf einmal das äh Gespräch der Woche und ähm nicht ganz so unrecht.
Ja, möchtest du erklären, was es ist?
Kann ich mal, kann ich.
Diejenigen, die noch nicht in diesen exklusiven Club eingeladen wurden.
Genau, also erstmal, was ist Clubhaus? Clubhaus ist äh zunächst einmal eine App für iOS, das heißt, es läuft aufm iPhone und es läuft auf dem iPad, dass die beiden Möglichkeiten teilzunehmen, derzeit eine andere Möglichkeit gibt's nicht
Ähm da ist auch nichts im Web und da wird auch meiner Meinung nach nie was im Web sein, so wie die äh App funktioniert, ist es, glaube ich, auch.
Gar nicht so ohne weiteres äh äh denkbar. Angeblich wird an einer Android-Version gearbeitet, wann die rauskommt.
Kann ich nicht beurteilen, ist zunächst einmal auch egal. Was macht jetzt das System? Das Ganze ist im Prinzip ein Online-Voice.
Raumsystem. So, das heißt, man äh hat
äh einen Account, man hat so ein Follower-Modell, man kann Leuten folgen, man wird von anderen Leuten gefolgt und auf der Basis dieses sozialen Grafen
Räume, die existieren angeboten und man kann dort hinein wechseln und dann erstmal zuhören äh jeder Raum ist so gestaltet, dass es dort eine Bühne gibt, auf der man,
mitsprechen kann.
Oder man befindet sich einfach im Teilnehmerraum in der Audience und dann kann man halt entweder die Hand heben und sagen, hier nimmt mich doch mal bitte auf die Bühne und einen Moderator kann ein Hoch holen.
Oder man wird angesprochen von den Moderatoren und eingeladen dort diese Bühne zu betreten, dann wandert das eigene Icon nach oben. Das ist dieses äh,
hochziehen, was ich so ein bisschen als Sprachgebrauch etabliert hat. Und dann kann man halt jederzeit mit anderen Leuten sprechen. Und man muss sagen,
Das funktioniert,
doch ausgesprochen wurde. Die Welle, die jetzt äh über Deutschland hereingebrochen ist, wurde so vor anderthalb Wochen ausgelöst, als ähm Leute, die aus,
anderen Gründen da schon einen Account haben, sich ein bisschen rumgeschaut haben, irgendwie strategisch über ihren Podcast
Invice verteilt haben und Hörer aufgefordert haben, die dann doch strategisch unter anderen Hörern zu verteilen. Na ja und dann war dann irgendwann so dieser Tipping Point erreicht, wo es dann einfach mit R gleich zwei äh vollexponentiell äh abging, uns dann die,
klassische Twitter äh Social Digital Blase, Journalisten, Politiker und viele andere Gruppen auch noch erwischt hat
Und dann war natürlich dann irgendwann dieser Tipping Point erreicht, wo einfach äh niemand mehr über irgendetwas anderes redete. Ich bin dann auch dazu gestoßen, habe.
In der letzten Woche extrem viel Zeit damit verbracht, muss ich sagen und bin ziemlich begeistert, dass es äh funktioniert wirklich ausgesprochen gut und ich habe an sehr vielen interessanten Gesprächsrunden äh teilgenommen und das bringt.
Wirklich auf Ideen. Jetzt ist natürlich Clubhaus.
Spaltet so ein bisschen die Gemüter, weil natürlich auf der einen Seite sich dann eben die Android erstmal ausgeschlossen fühlt. Klar, natürlich, äh genauso wie das andersrum auch wäre, wenn es jetzt auf Android erstmal nur eine App
gebe, äh die auf Eiweiß nicht verfügbar ist, da kann ich es relativ wenig dran ändern, ist halt so
und ähm andererseits äh sind sie natürlich dann vor allem auch darüber aufgefallen
dass sie ja durch dieses Invidee-Modell, also offiziell versteht sich diese App noch im Beta-Modus und verteilt nicht einfach freie Accounts, sondern man kommt halt nur rein, wenn man eben so,
in weit hat. Und technisch ist es halt so gelöst, dass ein Invest quasi.
Als Schlüssel eine Telefonnummer benutzt. Und das bedeutet wiederum, die App möchte gerne, um die Invites, die wenn du einen Account hast, ähm hast du erstmal zwei.
Äh und um die ausspielen zu können, fragt die App nach Zugriff auf dem Adressbuch auf dem Telefon.
Ja, das geht überhaupt nicht. Sorry. Also ich ich will mal kurz zumindest, also es gibt ein,
Also man kann verstehen, warum die gewillt sind, das an die Telefonnummer zu binden, ja? Ähm ich habe den Eindruck, so von der, von der Experience dort, ja, wenn du dich da anmeldest, sagen sie auch übrigens, hier verwendet man Klarnamen,
ja? Und wir registrieren dich auf deine Telefonnummer. Ähm ich vermute, dass die bemüht sind,
von vorne herein, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen eine eine Kultur versuchen zu etablieren, dass die Leute sich dort benehmen
Ja, ähm ob das jetzt tatsächlich
daran liegt, es gibt ja relativ viel Forschung, die sagt, das ist eigentlich unerheblich, ob du unter Klarnamen agierst oder nicht, wenn man sich den ganzen Hass bei Facebook versus Twitter anschaut, gibt's da keinen großartigen Unterschied, ja? Aber die das binden an eine Telefonnummer.
Ist natürlich,
relativ effiziente Methode, zum Beispiel äh viele Fake-Accounts äh zu verhindern, ja? Ähm zum Beispiel Leute, äh Leute.
Ja äh ein Signal zu geben, dass sie dass es potenziell
Was kostet, wenn man hier gesperrt wird und sich neu anmelden möchte und so, ja, also das das sind alles Überlegungen und das kann man von mir aus auch so machen, ist ja deren System, deren Regeln. Aber wenn ich ähm,
über Telefonnummern einlade, ja, dann erwarte ich eigentlich zum Beispiel spätestens, dass die mir ermöglichen, eine Telefonnummer einzugeben. Das tun sie aber nicht. So, ich habe jetzt da diese zwei Invites und kann sagen,
OK ich möchte die verteilen dann sagt der OK gib mir dein komplettes Adressbuch. So finde ich inakzeptabel und da hab ich übrigens auch direkt 'n Feature fest an Apple.
Wenn du nämlich in so eine App gehst, die ähm auf deine Fotos zugreifen möchte, ja? Dann kannst du.
Von IOS aussagen, welchen Zugriff du gibst und du kannst dann zum Beispiel sagen, ja, ich gebe dir Zugriff auf die Fotos, aber nur auf folgendes Album.
Ja, du kannst also jetzt zum Beispiel sagen,
ähm was weiß ich, du hast irgendeine App, neben war, ich nehme jetzt WhatsApp, weiß aber nicht genau, ist bei, also müsste bei WhatsApp genauso funktionieren, wie bei jeder anderen. Und dann sagst du, ja, okay, der darf auf meine Fotos zugreifen, aber nur auf einen spezifisches Album.
Und in dieses Album legst du dann die Bilder rein, die Mames, die du über WhatsApp verschicken willst, ja? Ähm und sperrst somit die Aus vom Vollzugriff auf deine äh auf alle. Und das Gleiche wäre eigentlich schön, wenn,
iOS das Betrieb von Betriebssystemebene aus äh auch machen würde für Kontakt.
Dass man nämlich sagt, aha, du hast hier eine Klapphaus-App, die möchte Zugriff auf deine Kontakte haben, möchtest du denn Vollzugriff geben,
oder möchtest du vielleicht einfach nur eine Kontaktgruppe geben, wo nur drei Leute drin sind? Nämlich die drei, die du jetzt vielleicht auch zu Klapphaus einladen möchtest.
Was jetzt hier passiert ist, ist also bei mir war das zum Beispiel so, ich habe.
Habe mich dann da einfach mal angemeldet und dann war ich in so einer Warteschlange. Ne, also ich hatte gar keinen Invide. Ich habe einfach nur einen Nutzernamen reserviert,
und dann kam irgendwie so eine viertel Stunde später so, ja hier ähm Johnny Häusler hat dich reingelassen, Johnny Häusler von Spreeblick äh und Republika, Gründer, ne, habe ich mich natürlich sehr gefreut, habe mich auch bedankt, aber konnte daran natürlich auch erkennen, alles klar,
Johnny Holster hat offenbar sein äh ne diesen Adresskontaktabgleich da gemacht und,
irgendeine Magie ist passiert, dass wahrscheinlich so spekuliere ich. Dadurch, dass ich mich da mit dieser Telefonnummer angemeldet habe, bei ihm dann erschienen, hier guck mal.
Linus, der, der ja unter deinen Kontakten ist, der möchte diese App nutzen, willst du dem in einen von deinen Invites opfern oder nicht? Und der Johnny war so freundlich, das zu tun,
Ich wiederum habe aber Kontakte in meinem Adressbuch und zwar nicht wenige, wo ich weiß, dass die das als schweren Vertrauens äh als schwere Vertrauensverletzung sehen würden, würde ich ihre Telefonnummern an diesen Dienst melden samt Namen.
Und deswegen kann ich das gar nicht machen. Also alle, die mich jetzt nach Invites angebettelt haben, musste ich leider vertrösten. Deswegen würde ich mir eben wünschen,
Ebene hier diese Telefon- und Kontaktfreigabe auch ähm,
ja, regulierbar, steuerbar durch die Nutzerin wird und nicht so 'ne alles oder nichts Funktionalität ist.
Dazu muss man nochmal sagen, äh das, was dir dazu Teil wurde, hat bei ihm noch nicht mal einen Inhalt verbraucht. Der Invite ist nur erforderlich, quasi, um neue Telefonnummern äh zu aktivieren.
Hätte ich mich ja gar nicht bedanken müssen. Das heißt.
Von Johnny war hier gar nicht so.
Nee, die war nicht besonders groß. Es ist einfach im laufenden Betrieb äh dürfte da so eine Meldung gekommen sein. Ach ja, hier, Linus ist da, äh willst du den mit reinholen? Ja, zack, bumm. So, das kann man halt so.
Entdanke ich. Dann äh danke ich.
Genau und äh danke, ne. Wieso immerhin hat er sein Adressbuch hochgeladen und damit war dann sozusagen die Information schon mal da. Das heißt, du warst dann und das ist jetzt auch der problematische Punkt. Äh denn.
In dem Moment, wo sie äh es auf Zugriff äh fragt. Äh weist nicht darauf hin, dass das jetzt alles komplett ausgelesen und hochgeladen wird.
So und an der Stelle haben die halt ein echtes Problem
und äh die Debatte ist allerdings jetzt auch schon angekommen, das muss man jetzt mal auch gleich dazu sagen, ja, also es gibt schon die Ankündigungen und Ankündigungen heißt in diesem Fall, es gibt da so ein wöchentliches Clubhausmeeting mit den Entwicklern
an dem man dann auch teilnehmen kann, ja? Ist alles so Audio, alles Real und wird vor allem alles nicht äh aufgezeichnet, sage ich gleich nochmal was dazu. Ähm wo,
ich hab's jetzt nicht selber, aber da ist nicht selber dabei, das ist jetzt ein bisschen hören, sagen, aber im Prinzip ist die Aussage, dass sie das ändern
werden, denn damit bekommen sie natürlich auch enorm äh Ärger, so wie WhatsApp damit auch schon
Ärger bekommen hat eigentlich alle. Ähm ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig den Überblick, ob's denn überhaupt derzeit noch eine App
äh äh gibt, die das so wirklich so konsequent ohne Weiteres äh macht. Bei Telegram war das ja auch so. Auch Signal fragt ja nach Telefonnummern und matcht über Telefonnummern, aber sie laden halt nicht das ganze Adressbuch irgendwo hoch.
Nee, die matchen vor allem auch mit gehäshten Telefonnummern. Also die laden nicht das Adresse.
Ja klar, also es ist sozusagen die die Frage ist, was machst du jetzt? Äh ich hätte ja gar kein Problem damit, wenn sie auf das Adressbuch Zugriff erlangen in der App,
ja? Und dann sagen, okay, jetzt will dem mal jemanden aus, den würdest du gerne einladen, so Ash und so weiter und dann, wenn sich jemand mit dieser Telefonnummer anmeldet, die auf diesen passt, dann also es wäre durchaus,
machbar gewesen, das auch anders zu lösen, aber das haben sie halt nicht getan, ne. Inwiefern das jetzt von denen so
gedankenlos war oder ach mal gucken, vielleicht merkt's keiner oder stört ja sowieso niemanden und es wird schon irgendwie funktionieren, kann ich nicht beurteilen. Tatsache ist, dass es da zu Recht derzeit eine Menge
Diskussionen drum gibt, ich rechne auch damit, dass sie jetzt grade durch diese neu gewonnene Popularität in Deutschland,
da sehr schnell handeln müssen, weil das natürlich auch alles datenschutzrelevante äh Dinge sind und da wird's sicherlich nicht dauern, bis da äh losgeklagt wird.
Ich spekuliere jetzt mal, ja? Ich glaube, dass das einfach verboten ist, was die tun,
Ähm wie gesagt, ich bin keine Anwältin, aber ähm es gibt ja schon die Urteile zu diesen,
wir haben das hier vor längerer Zeit auch schon in Lokbuch Netzpolitik damals immer diskutiert. Die sogenannten Freundefinder, ja? Das waren ja dann, also das war so, du meldest dich bei, ich glaube, LinkedIn hat das gemacht, Facebook hat's auf jeden Fall gemacht. Du meldest dich dort an.
Und er sagt, ey jo, voll geil. Du bist ja jetzt hier bei äh auf LinkedIn und so, ne, dein Leben wird jetzt besser sein
und ähm am besten wird dein Leben vor allem, wenn du jetzt äh alle deine Freunde hierhin einlädst, damit wir Kontakte hast und nicht in diesem sozialen Netzwerk alleine bist,
doch mal ganz kurz Zugriff auf deine Adressbuch frei, dann schicken wir mal an dein komplettes Adressbuch, dass du jetzt hier bist, dann können die Leute dir folgen und die die was sie gemacht haben ist, die können die Leute auf deren Namen,
LinkedIn-Accounts, oder Facebook-Accounts registriert waren. Die haben sie dann automatisch quasi in der App gesagt, ey jo, der ist jetzt da, willst du dem folgen, net? Ein Freund.
Was weiß ich so und so ist jetzt bei LinkedIn hier klicken um um zu gratulieren oder was auch immer, ne? Und bei denen, die nicht bei LinkedIn waren, haben sie dann halt eine Mail hingeschrieben und haben gesagt, ey.
Dein Freund XY ist bei LinkedIn. Du verpasst hier wirklich was, klick hier um Teil unseres Netzes zu werden. Und das ist natürlich also ein Missbrauch von persönlichen Daten für Werbezwecke. Das ist ähm
das Bereitstellen dieser unwissenden Personen von personenbezogenen Daten dritter für deine Plattform und das ist sinnvoll und richtig,
dass das äh verboten ist und verboten gehört, ja? Und ähm.
Da sehe ich eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Diskussionsrahmen. Da braucht man auch kein für und ich gehe davon aus, dass das,
so juristisch nicht haltbar ist. Wie gesagt, ich habe ihnen aber kein kein Anwalt und keine Richterin, aber ich sehe keinen Unterschied zu diesen Freundefinder-Funktionen, die ähm ich die in Deutschland dann,
mit äh mühseligen Verfahren, aber eben einschlägigen Urteilen dann eben auch verboten wurden. Und da sehe ich hier keinen Unterschied.
Ich auch nicht. Also, das wird sicherlich kommen. Insofern kann man sich auch durchaus mal,
davon von dieser Diskussion befreit da mal anschauen, was diese App jetzt selber ermöglicht und
Ich kann nur sagen, also es gibt da grade viel Hype drum, aber der Hype ist auch berechtigt. Also da ist halt wirklich äh was zu holen. Ich finde, das ist eine extrem angenehme,
Kommunikationskultur und ja, wir wollen ja da auch mal ein bisschen experimentieren, ob man da ein paar Feedback-Runden organisieren kann und wenn das so in den nächsten Tagen auch tun.
Das wäre jetzt ehrlich gesagt sinnvoll, das hier auch anzukündigen, Tim, wenn ich da mal freundlich anmerken darf, dass wir gerade einen Termin vereinbart haben, äh für die Nachbesprechung dieser Runde
in in Zusammenkunft äh mit der äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik Einhorn Standarte und zwar am Sonntag.
Den ähm vierundzwanzigsten Januar um einundzwanzig Uhrly im Klapphaus.
Und ja, also ich würde, also ich bin gespannt, ja, ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich für Podcasts und auch so für.
Podcast-Community, Feedback und so eine Möglichkeit ist, hier von diesen.
Von diesem hierarchischen Modell wegzukommen. Ja, es gibt ja ein, also ein allgemeines Ungleichgewicht, wenn jetzt jemand einen Kommentar.
Zu einer Episode Lokbuchnetzpolitik schreibt. Und zwar ist dieses Ungleichgewicht darin, erstens, ne, die Person hat nur muss schreiben, wird bei weitem nicht so von so vielen rezipiert wie der Podcast. Ähm zweitens,
Es ist irgendwie mehr oder weniger liegt's an Tim oder mir überhaupt diesen Kommentar in der Sendung vorzulesen.
Und zweitens, wenn wir es tun, können wir den auch nach Lust und Laune kürzen, was wir auch regelmäßig tun, ja? Und haben dann so viel Zeit wie wir haben, möchten.
Um darauf zu antworten.
Die Person das wiederum nicht mehr kann, ne? Also es ist total ähm unfair. Wir haben das ja hier vor äh einiger Zeit mal versucht, dem zu begegnen durch eine,
Telefonnummer, mit einem Anrufbeantworter, um euch die Möglichkeit zu geben, da ähm,
'ne 'ne Botschaft zu hinterlassen, das hat sich vermutlich deshalb nicht so durchgesetzt, weil,
es eben Anrufbeantworter ist, der live aufzeichnet und ich habe gesehen, dass andere da mehr äh glaube ich bessere Ergebnisse hatten mit WhatsApp-Sprachnachrichten, die wir aus.
Anlässen und Gründen, die wir nicht erläutern, brauchen äh eben nicht in der Lage sind, anzunehmen und auch äh hier nicht machen würden. Und jetzt sehe ich, glaube ich, mit diesem Klapphaus, das kann wirklich,
Weg sein, zu sagen, okay, die Inhalte der Sendung können.
Auf ein auf Augenhöhe in einer Community besprochen werden und auch im Dialog besprochen werden. Und das denke ich macht dieses System dann doch.
Enorm interessant und äh gibt dem tatsächlich ein Potential, ähm kann auch sein, dass ich mich da täusche.
Aber äh ich glaube, dass wir hier hoffentlich eine Möglichkeit haben, äh in den in den direkteren Dialog zu treten und,
ich hoffe ebenfalls, dass sich also diese Invite-Situation ist natürlich relativ durchschaubares Marketing, ja, also künstlich,
ist immer eine gute Idee äh auf sich aufmerksam zu machen. Da kann man sich drüber aufregen, das kann man auch ein bisschen gelassen sehen, ne? Früher oder später werden schon alle bei Klapphaus sein, äh die da sein möchten, weil Klapphaus hat mehr davon, wenn ihr dort seid, als wenn ihr nicht dort seid.
Diese Invitesituation finde ich absolut inakzeptabel und ich werd da deswegen auch mal garantiert niemanden in weiten,
und äh solange solange das äh erfordert, dass sich noch andere Personen Kontakte mit dieser Plattform teile, die äh von diesem Vorgang komplett unbehelligt sind und auch bleiben wollen.
Gibt natürlich auch noch einen anderen Aspekt, als jetzt nur das Marketing, ne. Äh man könnte jetzt noch argumentieren, das hat auch was mit Skalierungsfaktoren zu tun und man hat schon gesehen, dass das System in den letzten Tagen unter dem Ansturm der Deutschen auch äh äh ganz schön ins Flattern kam zwischendurch, aber im Großen und Ganzen noch
gut funktioniert hat, aber es gab zumindest schon.
Dumm der deutschen.
Ja, das war so. Also das äh innerhalb einer Woche ist die deutsche Community zur drittgrößten Community in in Klapphaus aufgestiegen und mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn sie äh da sogar noch den einen oder anderen Platz nimmt. Also okay, wenn ich größer als die USA kommen
Community, aber vielleicht größer als die Britische, ich weiß es nicht. Ähm was,
jetzt sozusagen gleich auf der Hand liegt, ist natürlich auch eben die Frage und das greift ja dann auch gleich wieder in die Diskussion, die wir so um Trump und Twitter und so weiter auch hatten. Was ist, wenn jetzt,
hier die Trolle übernehmen. Was ist, wenn jetzt sozusagen
Kommunikation reinkommt, die eben jetzt nicht so diese Blümchenwiesen Kommunikation ist, wie sie jetzt derzeit stattfindet.
Man hat äh derzeit sehr angenehme Gespräche mit Leuten, die
ähm Erfahrung haben. Es sind halt sehr viele Leute, die schon seit äh einem Jahrzehnt im Prinzip
teilweise auch online unterwegs sind und die einfach eine Kommunikationskultur drauf haben, die jetzt irgendwie nicht ja, nicht besonders schlecht ist, ne?
Gesehen davon, dass auch wirklich viele
Moderatoren unterwegs sind und sich hier ausprobieren und äh Rhetorik, Trainer und keine Ahnung, wer da noch äh alles unterwegs ist, auch sehr viele Podcasts da.
Und trotzdem muss eben dieses System treu resistent werden. Es muss in gewisser Hinsicht hier
auch äh Widerstandskraft entwickeln und tatsächlich gibt es im System auch schon so eine Funktion,
die basiert eben auch teilweise auf diesem Invitation System. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man sagt, ah, hier, den muss, der dreht aber hier total frei, den muss ich jetzt mal melden
dann äh kann es sein, ich habe das noch nicht in Aktion gesehen, aber so wird es ähm von den Regeln kolportiert, dann kann es eben sein, dass die Person, die äh hier auch eingeladen hat, unter Umständen auch gleich mitbestraft wird. Also so dieser soziale Graf kann jetzt hier sozusagen auch gleich noch so ein Bestrafungs äh Graf sein
Wie sich das ausspielt, ob das schon mal groß zum Einsatz gekommen ist, weiß ich alles derzeit noch nicht.
Aber das sind auf jeden Fall interessante Überlegungen, die dann auch wieder nochmal ganz
andere Implikationen haben können. Im Positiven vielleicht, wie auch im äh Negativen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessantes Experiment, das zu begleiten. Noch ganz spannend sein wird. Ähm,
wer jetzt der Meinung ist, och äh daran will ich eh nicht teilnehmen, aber wäre toll, dieselbe Funktionalität zu haben und wir haben doch und so. Klar, es gibt so Open Source, ähm
Lösung oder es gibt auch Discord-Server, wo natürlich eine Audiokommunikation auch möglich ist, aber so wie Twitter dieses Follower-Modell in diese Welt gebracht hat und das irgendwie so, als man das das erste Mal gesehen hat, gleich gedacht hat, so, oh
Ja klar, natürlich. So. So wird ganz viel in Zukunft funktionieren.
Glaube ich, wird dieses Stage-Modell, was hier bei Klapphaus äh implementiert worden ist, auch ganz schnell in diese Audiokonferenz Geschichte mit eingehen, weil das ist einfach auch so, wenn man das einmal gesehen hat, denkt man sich so, ja, klar, warum nicht gleich so? Also es funktioniert einfach so gut,
dass äh dass das sozusagen im Prinzip jetzt schon der Goldstandard ist.
Ja, okay, aber ähm ich würde an dieser Stelle jetzt vielleicht auch darum bitten, dass wir äh dass du weitere äh Lobpreisungen der Goldstandards äh in die Freakshow verschiebst.
Ja, gut, aber ich meine, ist halt so.
Ist halt.
Wir sind aber hier nicht da, um zu loben, sondern wir sind hier, um zu taddeln. Und äh deswegen würde ich jetzt gerne äh.
Auf Deutschland einschlagen.
Deutschland einschlagen, ja? Also nur um mal hier dabei zu sein. Wie gesagt, merkt euch, wenn ihr möchtet, äh kommt ihr am.
Sonntag, den vierundzwanzigsten Januar um einundzwanzig Uhr.
Zum Treffen der äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik Einhorn Standarte auf Klapphaus. Äh mein Accountname zum folgen ist dort,
wie auch übrigens bei Twitter und dein Account-Name Tim ist wahrscheinlich Tim Pritlaff in einem Wort, oder?
Wunderbar, wir freuen uns auf euch. Bitte keine Invites Batteln, ähm solange iOS kein Feature hat, äh mein Adressbuch vor solchen Apps zu verstecken, werde ich das nicht freigeben.
Ja und auch keine, bitte auch keine äh irgendwie explosionsdebatten. Wir,
testen da jetzt einfach mal äh aus, äh gucken einfach mal, was geht, vielleicht geht ja auch nichts und äh das müssen wir auch tun. Das ist im Prinzip wie so ein Hörertreffen irgendwo,
und äh da kann auch nicht jeder dran teilnehmen.
Ähm ja, also ich, wie gesagt, ich glaube, das ist ein Phänomen jetzt, was Marketing und Wachstum vereint, ähm aber, ja, das wird's nicht mittelfristig sicherlich.
In in Wolgefallen aufgelöst haben. Hoffentlich alle, alle Probleme, einmal dieses Invide-Ding und sicher, hoffentlich auch dieses Adressbuchding.
Kommen wir zum, zum, zu Deutschland. Ähm ich bin enttäuscht von was heißt enttäuscht von Deutschland, mein ganzes Leben, enttäuscht von Deutschland. Also aber ich bin äh ernüchtert, ja? Man hat ja ähm zwischenzeitlich so es gab so einen kurzen,
Sommer, wo man fast dachte, ey geil, wir sind wieder wer, ja, wir können wir können eine Pandemie bekämpfen, wir können äh.
Corona-Warn-App bauen ohne die Demokratie und die Grundrechte und irgendwie über Bord zu werfen.
Wir können.
Im, wir können PCR-Tests entwickeln und wir haben Aussicht darauf, dass wir vielleicht sogar 'ne 'ne Infrastruktur aufstellen, all das hat sich natürlich inzwischen tatsächlich sehr in, in Wohlgefallen aufgelöst.
Was man äh sieht, ist ja auch ein ein fortwährendes.
Gebäsche des Datenschutzes, ja? Der Datenschutz wird jetzt wieder für alles verantwortlich gemacht und man muss einfach sagen, es ist äh es ist immer wieder.
Wirklich bedauerlich, dass es.
Tatsächlich auch von denen getan wird, die, sagen wir mal, für die für das Ausmaß des Versagens eben auch verantwortlich sind. Ähm ein schönes Beispiel ist, es gibt eine.
Open Source Software mit dem Namen Sormas. Und diese Open Source Software.
Dazu geeignet, den Prozess, der ähm Kontaktnachverfolgung durch die Gesundheitsämter digital zu stützen. Sorma steht für.
Management, ja? In dieser Stelle ist diese medizinische
Ähm ich weiß, dass es da Anfang äh der am Anfang der Pandemie noch ganz viele gab, äh die irgendwo gesehen haben, boah, das RKI macht, oh, jetzt wissen wir, dass die Demokratie abgeschafft wird. Nee, also es ist ein.
Epidemiologischer Begriff, ja, die, der, der Überwachung des Infektionsgeschehens, der hier gemeint ist und ähm.
Diese Software gibt es, glaube ich, auch schon länger, ja. Es gibt auch das DMIS, das Deutsche elektronische Melde- und Informationssystem für den Informationsschutz,
das vom Robert Koch-Institut bereitgestellt wurde und Sormas, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, vom Helmholtz-Zentrum für Infektionsforschung.
Und ähm tja jetzt ist es so.
Der hat eine ich glaube eine der hat hier angefragt. So also Maria Klein,
Bundestages hat angefragt und geantwortet hat der parlamentarische Staatssekretär Thomas Gebhard, der, der ähm.
Offenbar ebenfalls Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestages ist unparlamentarischer Staatssekretär beim.
Ministerium für Gesundheit. Und der antwortet, war zum einunddreißigsten September zwanzig zwanzig in einhundertelf Gesundheitsämtern eingerichtet und betriebsbereit. Ja.
Und jetzt um diesen Wert zu beurteilen, muss man natürlich wissen, ja, wie viele Gesundheitsämter haben wir denn in Deutschland.
Und das sind dreihundertsiebzig. Also nur ein Drittel oder weniger als ein der Gesundheitsämter in Deutschland,
benutzt überhaupt eine digitale Lösung für das, was sie da tun, was ohnehin ja ein relativ langsamer,
Prozess ist. Ja? Die Bundesregierung hatte die Gesundheitsämter im Gesundheitsämter im November zwanzig zwanzig aufgefordert, die Software zu installieren, wo man sich auch fragt, warum haben die denn die Idee erst im November gehabt, ja?
Ähm dieses Sommers gibt's, glaube ich, schon länger und das wurde irgendwie für zur Kontrolle von Ebola,
glaube ich ursprünglich entwickelt. Das heißt, das hatten wir alles schon, ja? Aber bis zum Ende des ersten Pandemiejahres ist es nicht gelungen, dass bei mehr als ein der Gesundheitsämter zu installieren. Das, meine Damen und Herren, sind
Digitalisierungsversäumnisse, das sind die Sachen, die uns jetzt gerade äh Probleme machen, ja?
Äh kurz hinzufügen, also soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, den Plan einzuführen, gab's schon länger,
Der war aber ursprünglich eben für, glaube ich, für zwanzig einundzwanzig irgendwann im Laufe oder vielleicht zwanzig zweiundzwanzig war der Abschluss dieser Einführung vorgesehen und man hat versucht, das jetzt quasi wegen der Pandemie zu beschleunigen. Das,
Hat aber wohl noch nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Dem es äh wird tatsächlich bei allen dreihundertfünfundsiebzig Gesundheitsämtern ähm eingesetzt zum Empehmen von.
Meldungen, ja? Und die äh Labore haben sind verpflichtet, darüber zu melden. Ähm.
So, jetzt kommt, also ich halte ja ohnehin, das habe ich ja auch schon oft genug gesagt, diese manuelle Kontaktverfolgung durch die Gesundheitsämter bei den.
Jetzigen Inzedenzzahlen, auch wenn sie gerade ein bisschen sinken für letztendlich ähm ja.
Also vergebene Liebesmühe. Das wird keinen Effekt haben.
Bei der Eindämmung der Pandemie, weil die eben viel zu langsam sind und total überlastet sind mit dieser Aufgabe. Ja, das ist ja genau in dieser
schnellen Meldungen, schnelle Warnung. Das ist ja das, was die Corona-Warnapp machen soll. Übrigens auch nichts anderes, äh auch wenn das immer von vielen so behauptet wird. Und die Gesundheitsämter sind so überlastet, dass sie ja,
ähm mit mit also mitunter war das, äh ich glaube, als erstes haben sie dann da die Bundeswehrsoldaten hingeschickt.
Die dann da irgendwie mit ihrer sozialen Kompetenz äh die die Kontaktnachverfolgung am Telefon irgendwie durchführen oder so, muss man sich das vorstellen. Und jetzt sagen sie inzwischen.
Das mögen doch bitte die Studierenden in den Semesterferien machen. Also auch hier zeigt sich, das kann doch nicht, kann doch nicht wahr sein.
Ja, also da muss man sich ja nicht wundern, also wenn wenn wir solche Ansätze machen
ein Wildwuchs haben ne bei diesen wenn ähm einhundert
elf waren das jetzt, glaube ich, ne, oder etwas über hundert Gesundheitsämter, diese Digitallösung, diese einheitliche Standardlösung verwenden. Dann stellt sich die Frage, was machen die anderen zwei Drittel
Das heißt, die haben irgendwelche Individuallösungen und äh wir haben das ja hier auch schon in unseren Kommentaren gehört mit irgendwelchen Excel-Tabellen und so, ne? Das das heißt, da musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn die das nicht.
Nicht hinbekommen, ja? Und,
Studierende sollen für die bevorstehenden Semesterferien von Mitte Februar bis Mitte April gewonnen werden. Das ist echt eine nachhaltige Idee. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, wenn wir wissen, von Februar bis äh April können wir auf, auf Studierende setzen,
Du fragst, du fragst dich doch wirklich, was bei denen los ist, ne? Ähm.
Wildwuchs an Einzellösungen und das ist, wir haben bald, wir haben bald äh ein Jahr Pandemie, ne? Und das ist wirklich zum Heulen. Braucht man sich über diese ganzen Bildungslösungen gar nicht äh auszutauschen?
Es ist äh wirklich eine eine Katastrophe.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wo du die Zahl von dreihundertfünfundsiebzig äh Gesundheitsämtern hast.
Steht in dieser Antwort drin, also das äh steht weiter unten in dem Brief, den den, der jetzt hier von dem,
Bundesinnenministerium an die Anfragen beging, ich hab den gerade nicht mehr offen, deswegen Frau war das ja glaub ich und da steht drin dreihundertfünfundsiebzig Gesundheitsämter.
Kann auch sein, dass der also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die Zahl nicht korrekt ist.
Es sind meines Wissens über vierhundert, weil ich meine, wir haben auch vierhundertdreißig äh äh Landkreise. Da mag's sein, dass das ein oder andere Gesundheitsamt dann doch für einen mehr zuständig ist, aber äh soweit ich das sehe, sind's mehr als vierhundert.
Egal, es sind viele.
Musstest du denen mal Bescheid sagen? Vielleicht kannst du herausfinden, welche.
Vielleicht kennen die, vielleicht kennen die ja gar nicht alle. Ja, wir konnten das nicht überall installieren, weil wir nicht wussten, welche es gibt. Stand nicht in der Wikipedia genau drin.
So, dann haben wir, da werden wir uns hoffentlich bald in in einer Sendung auch nochmal diesem Ganzen digitalen Lern.
Äh Problemen äh widmen.
Ähm auch da sehen wir ja, wir haben's ja hier auch schon mal ab und zu kurz so ein bisschen aufblitzen lassen, dass das ja auch äh immer nur auch zwanzig einundzwanzig noch ein ernsthaftes Problem ist, den digitalen Unterricht irgendwie zu regeln
ja? Und das ist ja also du fragst dich ernsthaft,
wie wie dass da nicht alle sitzen und sich und und gemeinsam mit mit Hochdruck an den Lösungen arbeiten, sondern jetzt seit einem dreiviertel Jahr irgendwie äh engagiert. Schwarzer Peter spielen, das ist doch wirklich äh,
zum Heulen oder nicht?
Ja, es ist, glaube ich, nicht nur ein Problem
was man jetzt so auf die ähm auf die Regierung allein schieben kann, sondern ich glaube schon, dass wir auch so ein strukturelles gesellschaftliches äh kollektives Problem haben, dass einfach diese Akzeptanz solcher Systeme irgendwo auch.
Nicht nicht da ist. Und äh das sickert jetzt vielleicht langsam ein. Ich merke das ja so ein bisschen jetzt, wo die Schulen
äh mal wieder richtig zu sind. Jetzt müssen halt wirklich mal digitale Systeme benutzt werden und im Gegensatz zu März letzten Jahres sind sie jetzt eben auch schon äh äh vorhanden, zumindest in Teilen. Und man merkt langsam, wie bei den Lehrern, aber auch bei den Eltern
so Widerstände aufbrechen
einfach so ein so ein Moment der Akzeptanz auch begonnen hat und dass man sieht so, ah ja, okay, es hat ja dann doch Vorteile und hm, wenn man sich ein bisschen drum kümmert, dann versteht man das auch. Also.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Prozess, der durch die ganze Gesellschaft geht und am Ende natürlich dann äh auch oben ankommen muss, um entsprechend geleitet werden muss. Also ich bin
Verhalten optimistisch, aber wenn man halt jetzt hier sich den Index äh vor digital Life long learning anschaut, der sich mal äh die Situation der EU angeschaut hat. So, da ist es halt Deutschland einfach letzter. So.
Also wir sind wirklich Platz siebenundzwanzig äh äh was sozusagen.
Das hätte ich ja nicht gedacht, Tim.
Nein, es kommt überraschend jetzt für dich. Ja, sorry, ja. So ist es leider.
Krass, ey. Obwohl wir doch grade äh so erst jetzt wir haben doch jetzt einen Computerraum auch in der Schule.
Kann doch nicht sein, echt? Ja, dass.
Du bist witzig.
Irre. Hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Das müsst ihr, also das wäre das könnte also um das das hieße ja, es gäbe seit wahrscheinlich zwei Jahrzehnten massive Versäumnisse, Tim.
Ja, das äh könnte, könnte natürlich sein.
Man mag's nicht glauben, aber äh es ist äh wirklich äh nahezu legen, ne. Also gut, ich meine, das ist jetzt hier eine Studie, die ich äh zitiere, die sich das irgendwie anschaut, das ist jetzt kein internationales Ranking, aber äh da ist halt wirklich mal genauer geschaut werden äh worden, in welchen Ländern läuft's denn halt gut
und wo läuft's denn halt nicht so gut und wenig überraschend sind halt die äh nordischen
starten, also die baltischen und Finnland vor allem ganz weit vorne äh Island ist auch ganz manchmal, es geht auch über die EU hinaus. Äh Island ist auch ganz weit vorne und Italien nimmt halt den vorletzten Platz ein.
Deutschland nimmt den allerletzten Platz ein. So, während halt Holland irgendwie auf Platz zwei ist, also es ist ein kulturelles,
meiner Meinung nach und was genau an unserer Kultur kaputt ist in der Hinsicht, das das sollten wir uns vielleicht alle mal selber fragen.
Ja, dann haben wir, ich würde sagen,
Ja, die gute Nachricht kommt als allerletztes, also bleiben Sie uns gewogen. Ähm ich habe in letzter Zeit,
ähm ab und an mal äh ein einen Browser benutzt, bei dem ich ähm.
Entweder kein hatte oder einen,
Browser benutzt, wo der Cookie-Banner Blogger gewissermaßen kaputt war. Also, dass das,
der guckt, dass Cookie Banner nicht einfach vollständig weg war, sondern es wurde zwar nicht angezeigt, aber so diese
diese ähm Überlegung der Seite, sodass ich sie nicht nutzen konnte, blieb da, ja? Und dadurch bin ich mal wieder ein bisschen mehr auf Cookie-Banner,
aufmerksam geworden, die ich normalerweise sehr erfolgreich aussortiere. Und ich muss sagen, was da passiert, ist ja ähm.
Eine schwerwiegende Frechheit. Da werden ja alle Tricks genutzt, die also wirklich auch seit Jahrzehnten bekannt sind, um die Nutzerinnen dazu zu bringen, erst A alle Cookies zuzulassen.
Und B, alle Cookies zuzulassen, selbst wenn sie das nicht möchten. Ja, also der Klassiker ist äh hallo, wir brauchen Ihre Zustimmung, riesiger Knopf Zustimmung.
Kleiner, grauer Knopf,
ne, bei Sonnenlicht gar nicht zu erkennen, bewegt sich so, weg von der Maus, ja?
Ähm wo drauf steht, ich möchte individuelle Einstellungen vornehmen. Und wenn du auf individuelle Einstellungen vornimmst gehst, ja, dann werden dir da die kannst du da sorgfältig deine individuellen Einstimmungen nehmen und dann ist da drunter wieder der Knopf, so alle zulassen.
Und ein ganz kleiner, grauer Knopf so mit äh dieser individuellen Einstellung speichern bis zu meinem nächsten Besuch so ungefähr. Also.
Siehst du aber erst, wenn du ganz weit nach unten runter gescrollt hast ans Ende dieser Liste und da meistens auch noch, wenn du dann noch auf den zweiten Tab gehst, weil es beim.
Also asozial. Und durchschaubar. Und gemein und wirklich ähm glaube ich ehrlich gesagt also mit meinem Verständnis.
Ähm nicht zu also mit meinem rechtlichen Verständnis nicht zu vereinbaren, aber wie gesagt, mein rechtliches Verständnis ist auch nicht geschult. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das wie diese Cookie-Banner gebaut werden, ähm sagen wir mal, eine eine.
Sehr geschickt,
gemacht wurde von Psychologinnen und Juristinnen, um es gerade noch legal zu halten und trotzdem, sagen wir mal, die Konversionsrate, dass am Ende alle aus Versehen auf alle zulassen, klicken,
ungefähr bei neunundneunzig Komma neun Prozent zu halten. Also es ist wirklich ein absoluter Missstand. Immerhin äh sah hat das jetzt.
Justizministerium ja zumindest bei dem Missstand anerkannt, aber da gibt's auch eine sehr.
Also die die Meldung ist auch ne der also ich habe die bei Heise online hier mal rausgesucht äh,
Justizministerium will Cookie-Banner umgestalten. Gut, ja. Nach dem Willen eines Spitzenbeamten soll das äh aus dem Justizministerium soll das ablehnen der unbeliebten Cookies für Nutzer einfacher werden. Also da gibt's eine äh Willensbekundung eines Spitzenbeamten und zwar.
Staatssekretärs, ja?
Christian Castrop. So, der sagt, da muss was, da muss ich was tun. Dann wurde gefragt, naja okay, wie sieht's denn aus? Wann kommt denn das Gesetz, ja? Sind aber keine neuen Gesetze geplant?
Ähm und ähm jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
wie sich das Ministerium diesem Problem widmen möchte, ja? Man setzt also auf den Aufbau eines Kompetenzzentrums für Verhaltenswissenschaftliche Verbraucherforschung,
Darin sollen den Angaben zufolge Psychologen und Ökonomen gemeinsam arbeiten. Ja, Spoiler-Alert, genau das haben die Unternehmen und das ist das Ergebnis davon, ja. Ähm aber okay, man sagt, äh Vorgaben könnten also dann über die,
ePrivacy-Richtlinie der EU kommen und die wird ja derzeit verhandelt. Also man man äh möchte,
eventuell das Ganze nicht auf Deutschlandebene, sondern auf EU-Ebene lösen. Das klingt sinnvoll, weil wenn ich mich nicht täusche, kommen diese Cookie-Benner auch von EU-Vorgaben.
Und ja, es also es wäre wirklich schön, das mal zu lösen, ja? Das ist wirklich auch so eine, so eine absolute Frechheit, was was man da sieht.
Ja, also erstmal.
Technisches Stichwort ist hier Dark Pattern, ja, also diese Vorgehensweise, das solltet ihr euch vielleicht mal nachlesen. Dark Pettern, das sind sozusagen eben genau diese etablierten äh Methoden ein, dazu zu bringen, das zu tun, was man eigentlich nicht tun will
und das ist weit verbreitet nicht nur bei diesen Cookies. Und meiner Meinung nach,
einfach dieses ganze Anzeigen von Cookies, das ist etwas, was auf einer technischen Ebene gelöst werden muss. Das heißt, an meiner Meinung nach ist hier einfach auch,
äh W3C gefragt,
hier äh äh technische Lösungen zu liefern, dass man halt einfach Einstellungen machen kann in seinem Browser und sagen kann, ick will det einfach nicht. Egal, auf welche Seite man geht, dann ist es halt erstmal aus, aber wenn es eben wirklich eine funktionale Wichtigkeit,
dann äh kann man das dann auch explizit freischalten und dann ist das aber Teil der Browserinteraktion mit der Webseite und nicht ein Teil der Userinteraktion, der,
des Inhalts der Webseite mit mir und nur so wird es für alle in irgendeiner Form nett werden, weil es verhindert ja auch viele andere äh Sachen, ja, also.
Das ist übrigens äh gut, da äh ich will da nochmal ganz kurz was also gesetzlich ist das ja schon so, dass man sagt, okay, also einen für die Funktion notwendigen Cookie
Ja, beispielsweise, ne, du hast eine Login-Seite. Jemand sagt, ich logge mich hier ein, ja? Diesen Cookie, für den brauchst du keine Genehmigung, weil der ist für die Funktion notwendig. Du kannst
Login Funktion anbieten, ohne einen Cookie zu setzen, ja?
Und der, das ist ja ein Erstanbieter Cookies für die Funktion notwendig, brauchst du überhaupt gar keine ähm.
Brauchst du überhaupt gar keine Einwilligung für, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ja? Und.
Für Drittanbieter Cookies, also Nutzer, Verhalten äh Analyse und sonstige Scherze, Werbung und sowas. Dafür die darfst du nicht ohne Einwilligung machen, ja? Und.
Da fängt dieses Dark Padd halt nämlich schon an, dass die so tun, als bräuchten sie deine Einwilligung. Das ist nämlich, das steht als allererstes groß auf diesen Dingern drauf. Wir benötigen Ihre Zustimmung. Nein, benötigt ihr nicht.
Benötigt ihr nicht. Ich bin auf diese Seite gegangen und ich habe bereits zugestimmt, dass ich diese Seite benutzen möchte, ja? Und äh ich ich brauche keine Zustimmung, ein für die Funktion notwendigen,
Cookie hier äh zu setzen. Aber das ist ja auch nicht das, worum es denen geht. Das sind ja dann eben hier diese Liste mit Tracking und so weiter, dass du zustimmen sollst,
unnötige Cookies zu akzeptieren. Und ähm da sind ja genau diese kommen diese Dark-Pettens zum Einsatz, dass sie eine vollständig.
Ähm falsche Situation nahegelegt wird und dass deine Handlungsoptionen dir auch maximal verzehrt äh dargestellt werden und gleichzeitig ist ja wie so eine, ja, fast wie so eine ähm.
Anmutet, dass alle das machen, sodass sich, ne, das ist ja auch, ich hätte das in dem Vortrag hier in der Hacken auch nochmal behandelt, ne? Wenn du darauf trainiert bist hundertachtzigtausend Mal bei jeder Webseite auf diesen Knopf zu drücken.
Hast du ja dann auch diese Situation, dass auf einmal alle sich darüber beschweren und sagen, ja, also die EU-Gesetzgebung mit den Cookie-Bändern, das ist ja weltfremd, man kann ja keine Webseite mehr besuchen oder äh hier diese Einstimmung zu haben, weil weil
genau also ne, das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Du kannst keine Webseite mehr ähm besuchen, die nicht etwas macht,
was zustimmungspflichtig ist, weil es so asozial ist, ja? Und äh oh, können mich schon lange drüber aufregen. Ähm ich hoffe, dass dass der.
Staatssekretär Castrop uns hier ähm befreit. So und dann haben wir zum Abschluss eine gute Nachricht, Tim. Ich äh äh ich würde gerne das Jingle hören.
Die gute Nachricht ist, Donald Trump äh hatte das weiße Haus verlassen, äh hat sich irgendwie zum Golfen fliegen lassen
Ihr alle habt euch gefreut Tränen gelacht und so weiter. Es gab eine ja eine lustige in mit war dann doch über die Gäste
überrascht, ne? Also irgendwie Jennifer Lopez und Lady Gaga
ja? Waren äh da habe ich also erst hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass also die haben sich offenbar sehr viel Mühe gegeben ähm.
Ja, diesen, von dem Alter von Joe Biden nochmal abzulenken, ja? Und dann.
Dann gab's noch eine Poetin, die jetzt äh sehr bekannt geworden ist, äh weil alle sehr äh angetan waren von äh Menta Gorman, ja, es war sehr schön, aber ähm ich denke, so,
Das Internet hat dann den Preis ähm Bernie,
gegeben, der äh mit seinen Handschuhen da irgendwie in einer besonders guten Pose saß und jetzt gerade äh in ungefähr jedes historische Bild reingephotoshopt wird. Also ist hier der bleibt der,
der Präsident der Herzen.
Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist ähm Biden hat ja dann direkt, ich weiß nicht, sieben oder acht erlasse da irgendwie direkt unterzeichnet, die das Team schon vorbereitet hatte.
Und eine Sache, die äh stattgefunden hat, direkt am einundzwanzigsten Januar ist das der Michael Pack von Voice of America,
seinen Rücktritt eingereicht hat, eben auf das Drängen.
Der äh beiden Administration, ne, also mit anderen Worten, ne, du sagst den Leuten, wir feuern dich, wenn du jetzt nicht zurücktrittst, so gehe in Würde, das hat ja dann, also würde, das hat er gemacht und Michael Pack war derjenige, der das Ziel hatte.
Ähm ähm den Open Take Fund hier ähm kaputt zu machen.
Ähm und da sehr möglichst vieles getan hat, um da auf der,
bürokratischen Ebene den Open Tac kaputt zu machen. Open tag fand eben das äh ich hatte das in der Sendung damals erwähnt, dass Förderprojekt für ähm.
Tools, die im weitesten Sinne Dezentralität, äh Zensurumgehung.
Und oder Überwachungsumgehung fördern. Ähm berühmte Projekte aus dem Bereich sind, dass äh Torprojekt äh Signal,
Ähm Delta-Chat hat, glaube ich, auch wahrscheinlich vom OTF eine Förderung bekommen. Äh und eine Reihe anderer äh kleinerer Projekte wie was weiß ich, Uni.
Ähm und.
Schaut euch die Liste an, viele wichtige Projekte in diesem Bereich wurden vom gefördert. Ich selbst hab auch in zwei Projekten gefördert, die da.
Ähm gearbeitet, die da gefördert wurden. Äh das habe ich ja hier zur Transparenz nochmal angegeben. Und es sieht so aus, ja, dass jetzt äh zwar noch einige,
ähm ja, bürokratische Hürden im Weg sind, aber dass der Open Tech Fund relativ zeitnah wieder so operieren kann, wie er wollte. Und dieser
koordinierte Angriff der Trump Administration, der ja hier auf diese komische YouTube Call In Show von Steve Bennon zurückgeht, wo Namen genannt wurden
Ben sich Notizen gemacht hat und Libi Lu dann irgendwie eine Woche später gefeuert wurde.
Ähm das ist jetzt scheint abgewandt zu sein. Der Drops ist noch nicht gelutscht, aber dieses Problem äh wird sich hoffentlich bald wieder lösen. Das entbindet natürlich uns nicht von dem Missstand, dass wir ein ähnliches Förderprojekt selbstverständlich,
von diesem Ausmaß auch in Deutschland benötigen.
Aber das war, das war äh hiermit die gute Nachricht und äh wir haben ja gesagt, wir müssen uns ein bisschen kurz fassen, das tun wir hiermit.
Ich erinnere nochmal an unsere Clubhaus Experiment am Sonntag um.
Einundzwanzig Uhr und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wir das vielleicht jetzt so die nächsten Wochen mehrmals.
Versuchen werden. Vielleicht kann man sich den Termin dann schon mal, wenn ihr jetzt diese Sendung erst nach Sonntag hört, könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich darauf vorbereiten, dass wir das nächsten Sonntag äh nochmal versuchen werden.
Dann war's das von uns für diese Woche und äh feiert noch schön, was auch immer ihr zu feiern habt.
Vor allem viel.
Und dann sehen wir uns.
Weißt du, was die jetzt rausgefunden haben, Tim? Die finden ja alles raus, ne. Jetzt haben sie rausgefunden, dass die Deutschen, die Corona-Einschränkungen zunehmen, belastend finden.
Ernsthaft? Krass. Das ist äh das äh kommt jetzt ein bisschen, das schockiert mich jetzt ein bisschen.
Die kriegen alles raus.
Alles raus, das stimmt. Aber wir kriegen ja auch alles raus.
Alles raus.
Ist die Balance wieder gewahrt.
Das ist sie.
Wieder hin Leute äh und schlaft noch schön. Äh wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao ciao.